are you guys swapping out pilots no no
we were what the book is that supposed
to mean Jack there seems to be a lot of
mountain collisions or just a girl with
less mountains its strategic I'm
spraying must burn oh they love us guys
crashing into each other all right you
can definitely see where the party
Buffalo you'll get back still still how
do you see the whole way
no oh so sounds of mazel all right horns
of war great birthright dead ahead let's
kill it who's a kid I'm warning for no
market you want a ranger night mark you
want to rent him a gun no let's not try
to do anything too fancy inspired uh we
hate a gopher inspired okay clarity Bob
go down as a speech I'm a-goin try not
to crash in this game as your ground has
been up your grun has been up grunting
updates your own all inspired us in such
trouble
I thought they died already oh I hit him
geez I can't even see him yeah see
that's all right all right uh which
switch to burn afraid switch to vertebra
get him get him get him
pig that every flavor drink good job
grumps I apologize for your pirating
skills I'm slightly crashing into
everything crossfire [ __ ] Britta brain
let's go
I'll take they can hear us my replies
either I can't tell where they are
they're light on us okay that was a
teammate that went down nice mountains
yeah yeah yeah oh [ __ ] yeah oh Jesus Wow
oh [ __ ]
rock and steel butterfly needs to die
I'm I'm gonna go underneath steel
butterfly because I can't hit him
anymore this fire is [ __ ] us up right
now get away from this uh inspired is
right next to it yeah we gotta get away
I'm going frontal burning turning
engines right now turning on them I'm
trying to pop their balloon why is it oh
[ __ ] that one down well hey okay we need
to we need to go up we need to go up up
up we're going we're going cut okay I'll
hold down up no God no God
Oh keep that balloon alive wait keep
that balloon alive alright dream alive
if we lose that balloon we go down and
we don't down his death really wasn't
working in air below I didn't realize
down was bad okay yeah we have we got
trouble Brewin okay inspire inspired is
turning on us they're turning to fire
yeah we got our really pyramidion over
there so why are they not helping us
okay would you stay I'm Sayla keep the
like stay here Jack we got this I'm on
it
keep keep keeping us alive you got it
I'm doing the banging then they're just
out of range of this gun after [ __ ]
watch out I keep spitting up yeah let me
try to hit steel butterfly okay steal
butter find out okay well alright okay
up here we go oh
don't spray the whole jack it was on
fire yeah but it was dead gosh oh honey
oh they're crashing to each other keep
in and keep it and keep it and keep
hitting oh Jesus focus on this whole
hole
Oh Oh God
damn it's just like we we didn't have
anyone able to shoot back those the
issue yeah all right our teammates are
backing off so hopefully if we can spawn
here quickly
yeah is that the grumps are they backing
up heavily yeah it looks like hope so we
can do this we can come up right on
there down yeah oh gosh
and after this first after that first
batch I'm really letting the side down
here hey where are you guys at right now
we're just coming up behind you yeah if
you're backing up like a crazy person
we're coming up on you we're right
behind you all right inspired hard it is
inspired is the one with the heaviest
firepower we just can't let them stay
alive like we got there boom oh my god
all right I couldn't see that through
the hole that was my bed thank you
I got Jax and the gun I got I got a guy
oh wait is three to two them yeah cuz
the we gots cut apart he paid them Jack
uh we have a buzzer balls there hold is
red a bird appraised coming in on us
right now
that's okay they're not coming in on us
they're coming in on our friendly spiral
let's focus bird of prey though cuz
everyone is shooting bird of prey okay
yeah alright I don't think the grumps
can hear us I don't think so I love the
thing
and hit a good shot good shot here yeah
just get rid of bird pray first and ah
fire coming in fire come in hey Jase
I'm gonna try to keep it inspired down
cuz if I got your they're all who knows
oh hold them going for it ooh man keep
petting I'm Jackie they hit us from way
far away God they wreck us with whatever
gun they got you hit that jag oh okay go
Jack go we got we got [ __ ] people are
trying to fire us
yeah good he's going on fire need help
with hole and then I'm gonna meet you
Kisan targets yeah we're what are our
friendlies go
let me mean this mean this okay you can
all hear it
mallets [ __ ] ah balloons on fire hey get
him Jackie I can't I can't I need left
juggle goddamn that oh my god got it
down
Oh God uh we're in a bad way here yeah
we are all yet holes having problems uh
we're about to run into bird of prey
alright those would mean addicted
I think that's worse for them than it
was for us the steel butterfly switched
out their main gun we got to get stop
getting broadsided by steel butterfly
cuz the wrecking our [ __ ] yeah once an
at hull okay steel butterflies on our
ass [ __ ] oh that's not good I know [ __ ]
yeah my god we are getting destroyed
yeah I thought we had to use the spinny
gun they have a good gun
yeah they switched out for the hwacha
yeah all right the devs told us to use
this gun they did well they did for at
least let's stay back and let's range
them while our friends engage okay okay
Berta pride just went down the grumps
just killed Berta way
yeah okay so we just got it okay they're
two on one now with them okay it's four
and four yeah we got it is we gotta use
our range to our advantage because the
main gun is a very long range gun
somebody get on the field gun and get
ready I'm gonna try and keep that on
target I'll try to do when I can wait
wait and I'll trade off well on jacket
switch for the field gun is that you
getting it yeah yeah Jack's got hits
it's so long
range okay four five two four I can't
see them though they're spotted I think
somebody went down which one is bad we
have two friendlies over there so if
someone went down it was an enemy yeah
that is inspired inspired inspired yep
I'm gonna turn sail a field gun is gonna
be on target yeah I got it got it mark
yeah
gonna hit their balloon good shots
that's a big ask on you oh they just
went barely out of range there I'm
turning I'm turning okay hang on a taboo
em out okay I don't think this I don't
think the field gun hits balloons very
hard I'll try it
he hit the mountain I'm gonna hit the
engine uh just out of my area of shotted
miss turn elidio how about 35 guys front
and bouff keep it that were five five
all right we got this part up right
front keep keeping inspired Jack if you
can get shots on vertebrae that's good
doing my best
are you still on target mark I'm still
on target okay and I'm on ticket out of
target all right uh no Jeff I wish did
you try and get Jack on target get Jack
on target he hits harder damn it they
just went one up on us
Oh weren't there backing up back up back
up back up hard cuz they're gonna swing
around the pyramid Ian's gonna lay into
us yep Oh Jake oh my god this is our
problem we get knee-deep in them
yeah okay I'm trying to get the engines
oh no that's stupid
Oh steel butterflies are em oh it's
gonna be us I'm gonna burn engine so we
can get out of here but yeah that's our
like our life preparing engines cuz
we're not going anywhere
no no no not us we counted one why did
the grumps guys back us up for God's
sake
oh we're alone and they're backing
further away from us no we were dead
well one of our allies just backed away
from this fight and now it's
three-on-one the dead look I got damn
dev ship they would okay alright I'm
gonna go I'm gonna go full core and
we're gonna [ __ ] we gotta get out here
we got to fix these I don't burn the
engines cuz they'll die okay okay well
we're gonna try to give you an escape
who's chasing you all of them oh okay
just we're going for inspired then okay
all right coming back away okay engines
are on hold get us out of here burn for
a little bit I'm gonna stay on the
engine just get us out of here I'm gonna
get us to range and then we can feel gun
them okay all right I ended up here
we're good we're good we're good we're
good we're solid okay we're far enough
away I think I stopped burnin okay
everything repaired spray everything
down remember to spray that was close
yeah that was pretty close the dev ship
really [ __ ] us there yeah bill
butterfly is to our writings got the
dead ship all right okay just don't die
guys so we're just gonna stay at range
and distract cuz we're in a bad way here
yeah all right we got to get in a little
closer though yeah I'm going oh geez
the shaky shakes all the sick yeah we
just hit the edge of the map work or
turn it back in
it's all right we've got one behind one
to the right and one is steel butterfly
right in front of you gross just let's
hit them let's focus steel bar is the
weakest we're watching them all right
hit him Jackie keep them hard aground
spin him around but I have no idea oh
there you go there you go just have
faith you got him if we get their
engines down we can kill them hidden
them oh we're gonna have to run past
them yeah they're going down to the
balloon just died yeah their balloon
Gatling Gatling on the right yeah oh
yeah the balloon dydz to the point where
they fell okay I might be able to hit
him just might be able to Artemis come
through yeah
ah good effort though that's was you
know if we didn't have the dev teams
should be a much more fun game